a seven-year-old girl has apparently
been shot dead in myanmar becoming the
youngest victim yet of the
military's crackdown on anti-coup
protesters
the family of kim mio chit told local
media she was sitting
on her father's knee when security
forces raided their home in mandalay and
opened fire
at least 20 children have been reported
killed since the military seized power
last month
this comes as pro-democracy activists
gear up for a nationwide
silent strike organizers are encouraging
businesses to shut
and asking people to stay at home
well for more i'm joined now by
correspondent tintin
yeo she is the managing director of
burma news international
based in bangkok thanks for being with
us this morning
centennial there are reports that a
seven-year-old girl was killed in her
home last night by the military what
more can you tell us about that
uh it is so shocking and also really
painful to see
that um day by day more and more people
are killed
at the same time young many young
children are also being the target
so this is showing that our country
is no longer safe and then the military
group
is controlling the country with fear
and also they are allowed they just
allow
their military soldiers to kill to just
to kill anyone that they see
and with impunity so um
so we we are so sad for the family and
that we really wish
that this kind of mass killing with
impunity
stopped soon that's why
we at the moment we don't know
what will be the right honestly um way
to
stop but uh but other people and they
say um
sentiments against you know the military
regime is never
strong so we we are still very hopeful
that we can end this kind of mass
killing soon
yeah we're hearing that the military
junta in
myanmar is preparing to release hundreds
of
prisoners is that the case
actually this morning like a more than
600
detainees were released they are mostly
students so it may be
relate related or it may not be because
like uh
today is the special day that every
every cities
in the country um honestly coordinate
for the
silent strike so maybe they try to bring
the people into the streets maybe that
is part of their
understand uh honest action that they
would like to show the world
everything is normal so that's why they
released um you know the the people but
we are so happy
whatever like a reason behind it we're
so happy that more than 600 i got
you know a protester were released 600
protesters released okay that's a that's
an important detail
uh does this suggest to you that the
military regime
is bending to the will of the protesters
briefly if you can i don't yeah i don't
really see in that way because this
the military regime that we are dealing
with they are
not uh how they say uh thinking uh
strategically
and also with like uh humanity so
uh they release these these um
protesters these detainees
maybe they have some other reason
because they are still more than two
thousand
uh people are behind bar
so like they just release some and
probably they may they will arrest more
so we can never say exactly what are
their
what will be their action because they
are no longer uh honestly working with
like humanity
tintin yo managing director of burma
news international talking to us from
bangkok thank you very much
thank you well being an activist
in myanmar is becoming increasingly
dangerous dw
spoke to one of the activists in the
country risking arrest
and her life fighting for freedom from
military rule
united in resistance a vast
range of anti-coup demonstrators and
helping them
organize is activist a vincer maung
her work puts her at risk of arrest we
caught up with her
at an undisclosed location
she says even if we are afraid we must
fight
it's anger against the military she says
that is helping people put aside their
differences
and protest
there is no army in this country at the
moment
which defends stability and peace of
citizens
there are only terrorists who destroy
stability
and peace of citizens and commit murders
the demonstrators want an end to
military rule
but a says a return to the democracy
myanmar new before the february coup
is not enough
there's a lack of acceptance for the
equality of all
ethnic people and autonomy
the neglect of the rights of ethnic
minorities
and the lack of a democratic system are
the reasons why the civil war in our
country
has lasted so long if we want to move
forward into the future
we must not take with us the things that
happened in the past
besides protests millions of people are
refusing to work
their aim to starve the junta of the
resources
to run the country but a says
international sanctions on
military-owned businesses
are also vital
i do really hope that people will stop
consuming
bloody products every single product of
the military has blood
and life of the people of our country
and many in myanmar are risking their
lives for freedom from the junta
[Music]
and despite weeks of a violent crackdown
and economic hardship
the resolve of the protest movement in
myanmar remains unbroken
you